mesdames et messieurs bonsoir au
sommaire de cette éviction la situation
en pologne où d'une part la radio a
transmis aujourd'hui pour la première
fois une messe mais où l'on a en même
temps l'impression qu'un étau se
resserre
ensuite les opérations militaires entre
l'iran et l'irak des troupes ont été
engagés sur terre sur mer et dans les
airs en france l'arrivée ce matin à
brest du morbihannais gérard d'aboville
qui a réussi la traversée seul à la ram
de l'atlantique nord
un grand exploit résultats du tiercé 11
17 et as et les grandes innovations à
haute loire en effet le niveau du fleuve
monde depuis ce midi notamment dans la
région du puy
à telle enseigne que la préfecture du
département a dû déclencher le plan
orsec car dans certains quartiers les
eaux monte très rapidement et l'on
déplore des morts et des blessés
une correspondance votre confrère jean
marie blanc du journal la montagne
m sélections très fébrile en effet
tragique et profonde et un 4 4 morts et
13 blessés et d'autres départements sont
également touchés surtout l'aveyron et
la lozère est aussi bien que moins
gravement le gamin divers endroits donc
aux dix noms des lignes téléphoniques
emporté car d'inaccessible telles sont
les conséquences des violents orages des
trombes d'eau qui se sont abattues sur
les régions que nous venons de vous
citer à chicago où les habitants de
souche polonaises sont si nombreux que
cette venue en fait la deuxième ville
polonaise du monde
le président carter ré affirmé que les
états unis n'interviendrait pas dans les
affaires de la paix règne ajoute pas en
substance j'espère que les autres pays
respecteront de même manille
le droit des polonais à résoudre leurs
divers problèmes tout ça ce matin à
varsovie la radio a transmis en direct
une messe célébrée dans une église de la
ville c'est une véritable première car
jamais une telle émission n'avait eu
lieu
depuis que la pologne et démocratie
populaire de thèse en direct était
d'ailleurs parmi les revendications
essentielles des ouvriers lors des
grèves récentes bien qu'il ne soit pas
facile je vais quelques jours en tout
cas pour les journalistes occidentaux de
faire ce qu'ils veulent tant pologne
voici le commentaire de l'envoyé spécial
d'antenne de felice santé de fidel
remplissait ce matin l'église 1/3 de
varsovie des idées venues participer à
cette première m transmises radios
officielles venues témoigner par leur
ferveur de l'immense joie des
catholiques polonais l'église où repose
le coeur de frédéric chopin symboliser
déjà le maintenir de max vie en 1944
depuis ce matin elle brise aussi une
victoire capitale pour l'église
polonaise
cet ep officiellement consacrée aux
médias
mais dans leur coeur les catholiques
polonais long dédié aux ouvriers de
gdansk
car ce sont de par leur grève qui ont
arraché des concessions crucial de la
part du pouvoir
ok
cette mais cette transmission c'est
pensable de reconnaissance de
l'influencent de la position de l'église
en pole effectivement ceci était une
demande formulée depuis de nombreuses
années par l'église de pologne que
d'avoir des cérémonie retransmise à la
radio et pour des grandes manifestations
à la télévision et bien aujourd'hui nous
avons donc satisfaction pour ce qui
concerne cette messe à la radio et c'est
une manière pour le gouvernement d'une
part de reconnaître encore une fois que
les accords de gdansk doivent être
appliqués dans leur complète acception
et ensuite c'est une reconnaissance
effectivement que l'église joue un rôle
important pour la population et que l'on
doit compter avec elle dans le destin de
la pologne
il n'y a pas que cet aspect de détente
et d'ouverture par d'autres côté par
d'autres étaient on a l'impression que
l'étau se resserre alors qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'une détente comment dire factice
effectivement à la date de ce dimanche
je dirais que nous sommes devant une
situation un petit peu indécise car d'un
côté il y à cette volonté d'appliquer
les accords de gdansk
mais en même temps la pologne se trouve
devant une volonté du parti de remettre
de l'ordre dans ses rangs à preuve les
deux limogeage qui viennent de se passer
de deux responsables importants du parti
dans deux provinces de pologne et en
même temps la semaine s'ouvre sur ce
fond de l'éditorial de la pravda d'hier
qui était un avertissement assez
solennel à la pologne et plus
particulièrement aux dirigeants qui est
un point limite était franchie à gnet ne
devait pas être franchies pour ne pas
que les acquis du socialisme puissent
être mis en danger les agriculteurs
polonais estiment que les ouvriers sont
avantagés par cet accueil culture
polonaise et pour 80 % fait de propriété
privée dont les 2/3 tourne autour de 5 6
hectares or en agissante avec un certain
savoir faire
les agriculteurs peuvent mieux vivre que
les autres catégories sociales polonaise
un reportage de l'envoyée spéciale
d'antenne 2 elisha t
il s'appelle eugène kaczorowski il a 61
ans il est agriculteur avec sa femme
léocadia et son fils valdemar il
exploite cette ferme avait peint des à
une vingtaine de kilomètres de varsovie
il a un peu plus de 8 hectares de terres
depuis des générations
sa famille habite cette ferme car eugène
kaczorowski et le propriétaire de sa
ferme
c'est l'un des grands paradoxes de la
pologne socialiste presque 80% des
terres agricoles sont privés dans un
pays où l'agriculture à garder un poids
considérable 15 % seulement du produit
national brut
mais un emploi sur trois pour les
citadins polonais confrontés à des
difficultés quotidiennes pour acheter de
la nourriture
les paysans font figure de privilégiés
on dit que les paysans polonais sont
défavorisés qu'en pensez vous mais ce
n'est pas de notre faute si les magasins
sont vite l'état ne nous donne pas les
moyens de produire plus il nous faut des
engrais des machines des aides
financières mais on ne nous aide pas on
dit tout le temps que ce sont les
ouvriers qui font vivre la pologne et
nous on nous oublie
regardez ces histoires de grève à gdansk
et ailleurs encore une fois tout va être
pour les ouvriers et cela ne changera
rien pour notre économie
je veux qu'on respecte les paysans par
exemple les bureaucrates qui nous
méprisent
non je ne crois pas que l'arrivée au
pouvoir de cagnes à changera quoi que ce
soit pour les paysans il sera comme les
autres il ne pensera qu'à lui-même
moi ce que je voudrais c'est plus de
machines agricoles et moins de discours
de dirigeants à la télé son vieux
tracteurs eugene katchalov qui
l'entretient amoureusement parce qu'il
ne sait pas s'il pourra en acheter un
autre
c'est l'état qui distribue les tracteurs
mais c'est aussi l'état qui peut lui
donner des semences des engrais des
aliments pour le bétail
alors ils passent des contrats avec
l'état en échange de tout ce dont il a
besoin
il promet de vendre à l'état au prix
officiel tant de kilos de pommes de
terre tant de chou temps de porc la
famille kaczorowski travail de douze ou
treize heures par jour je trouve ça
normal car dit-il si l'on veut vivre
bien il faut travailler beaucoup
le drame de gêne c'est qu'il sait que
son fils ne voudra pas reprendre la
ferme le moment venu le travail est trop
dure et waldemar qui a un diplôme de
mécanicien préfère faire ses huit heures
dans un atelier et avoir des vacances
comme tout le monde car chez les 14 qui
on travaille même le dimanche après la
messe
il faut aller aux portes de varsovie au
marché libre des fruits et des légumes
c'est ici qu'on gagne vraiment sa vie
car la loi de l'offre et de la demande
joue à plein et les prix officiels n'ont
plus cours
les acheteurs ne manquent pas ménages
est revenue et a cherché le beau chaud
pour le repas dominical mais aussi des
grossistes qui ont des magasins privés à
varsovie et qui compte sur la qualité et
la quantité de leurs étalages pour faire
accepter des prix nettement plus élevé
en ce seul dimanche
eugène kaczorowski gagnera 12500 le ti
soit plus de deux fois ce qu'un polonais
moyen gagne par mois
en pologne c'est l'agriculture privé qui
illustre sans doute le mieux le principe
marxiste à chacun selon son travail mais
revenons aux ouvriers alors pour eux la
semaine va être décisive et doivent
mettre en place sur le plan national les
syndicats indépendants dont ils ont
obtenu la création par leur mouvement de
grève joffredo comment les choses se
présentent a effectivement demain à
gdansk doit se réunir une nouvelle
assemblée générale de tous les syndicats
récemment créée en pologne hélas les
syndicalistes vont avoir le choix entre
trois possibilités ou bien créer je
dirais un contre syndicat officiel
rassemblant tout le monde ou bien
simplement une fédération d'unions
régionales ou encore simplement un
comité de coordination entre tous ces
comités et ils ont en principe ensemble
mercredi prochain demander leur
inscription au tribunal de varsovie
comme le conseil d'état leur en donne la
possibilité
et là on pourra mesurer d'une part l'
influence des uns ou des autres à
l'intérêt de ce mouvement et en
particulier le leadership que peut
exister exercer leurs balances à et
d'autre part qu'elle sera aussi
l'attitude du pouvoir car à partir du
moment où il y aura une volonté
d'appliquer réellement les accords de
gdansk donc de laisser faire
l'organisation des syndicats est bien le
pouvoir ne peut pas décemment comme on
dirait mettre des bâtons dans les roues
pour que ces syndicats puissent vivre
décemment
ce même donc qui s'annonce décisive les
combats font rage entre les forces
irakiennes à l'effort iranienne on
annonçait d'hamidi de violents
engagement dans la région du château
l'arabe c'est à dire la jonction entre
les deux grands fleuves le tigre et
l'euphrate
les opérations se déroulent sur terre
sur mer et dans les airs elle engage la
retirer des blindés les missiles bref
une vraie guerre bernard benyamin une
vraie guerre vous avez raison dont ces
quelques images nous sont parvenues il
ya quelques jours avec déjà des bilans
contradictoires selon bagdad cinq
vedettes iraniennes auraient été
détruits qu'il y aurait des dizaines de
morts
pas du tout affirme terence est un petit
bateau de guerre irakien qui a été coulé
en revanche c'est vrai que
oram chars le port commercial plus
important durant et la ville d'aba dans
qui abrite la plus grosse raffinerie de
pétrole du monde sont sous le feu de
l'artillerie raquette alors pourquoi
cette guerre exactement et égoïstement
quelles peuvent être les répercussions
sur les pays d'occident pourquoi cette
guerre là la réponse est officiellement
simple en tout cas c'est pour un litige
de frontières bagdad et téhéran
je discute quelques centaines de km² au
kurdistan dans le nord du pays dans le
nord de l'iran et résistant beaucoup
plus aussi dans la région du golfe c'est
d'ailleurs dans cette région que
j'allais rouler combats les plus durs
exactement sur le chat tu es laraque qui
constitue vous l'avais dit la jonction
entre le tigre et l'euphrate est en fête
et vous l'avez compris en regardant
cette car les deux pays se disputent
surtout le contrôle de la route du
pétrole et ce n'est pas un hasard si les
combats les plus durs se déroule au
khouzistan c'est la province la plus
riche d'iran où l'on trouve une
concentration énorme de puits de pétrole
de raffineries et de terminaux
pétroliers et les irakiens n'ont jamais
caché leurs revendications sur cette
région
d'autant qu'il y à deux millions
d'arabes civile dans cette région et qui
se réclame de bagdad
ils n'ont jamais caché non plus depuis
la chute du chah leurs prétentions à
prendre la relève des iraniens pour être
les nouveaux maîtres du golfe
tout cela avec en arrière-plan la
vieille la très vieille querelle entre
chiites qui sont au pouvoir en iran et
sunnites qui tiennent le gouvernement en
irak voilà pourquoi ce qui se passe dans
cette région nous intéresse directement
c'est une région un bip et de pétrole
l'occident serait en effet tôt ou tard
la première victime de cette guerre qui
a vraisemblablement commencé dans le
fond du golfe arabo-persique sous l'oeil
très attentif de son grand voisin du
nord
l'union soviétique aux etats unis la
campagne pour l'élection présidentielle
vient de commencer à la télévision trois
candidats principaux du mit carter
démocrate que malgré gamme républicain
et john anderson indépendants les
chaînes de télé américaines
j'aimerais bien les avoir tous les trois
sur plateau mais les candidats jouent à
cache cache ainsi dans le premier débat
organisé par la ligue des femmes
monsieur carter a refusé de venir et les
organisatrices avaient voulu souligner
son absence en leur présentant par une
chaise vide mais en fin de compte
d'accès guy eyermann
il n'y aura pas de chaise vide mais tous
les téléspectateurs américains penseront
au grand absent et john anderson de son
côté sait qu'il jouera une grande partie
de son avenir électoral
à l'occasion de ce premier débat
télévisé avec ronald reagan
premier point john anderson jouera-t-il
de la fameuse différence anderson sur
laquelle il a basé toute sa campagne
alors que cette différence donc est mal
perçue par le gros de l'électorat
américain qui serait prêt dit on à voter
pour lui s'il avait la certitude est la
conviction qu'il a une chance réelle de
remporter la victoire à la maison
blanche
or ça n'est pas le cas deuxième point
john anderson l'indépendant ancien
républicain et ronald reagan
monti veut réellement s'affronter ou
plutôt conjuguer leur ca tags sur jimmy
carter auquel cas il n'y aurait pas de
départ aujourd'hui tous les sondages
admettent que la candidature ederson est
plus dangereuse pour jimmy carter que
pour ronald reagan
car l'électorat potentiel d'anderson et
celui des démocrates déçus qu rencontre
notamment dans les états du nord-est
industriels là où justement carter doit
y gagne en novembre
s'il veut rester à la maison blanche
voici donc pourquoi jimmy carter a snobé
ce premier débat car il voudrait effacer
faire oublier cette candidature anderson
si dangereuse pour lui en revanche il
est prêt à rencontrer n'importe où et
n'importe quand ronald reagan
mais cette fois c'est reagan qui se fait
prier
un gouvernement civil a été formée en
turquie par la mer à la retraite ball
and blues ou ancien commandant en chef
des forces navales turques ce ministère
qui tient demain sa première réunion
comprend notamment des technocrates des
militaires et un journaliste
l'amiral hulu est âgé de 57 ans après 73
jours d'efforts le rameur solitaire le
breton gérard d'aboville a réussi le
grand exploit il a traversé l'atlantique
à la rame tout seul dans son bateau le
capitaine cook
nous allons revivre sa dernière journée
en commençant aux petites heures de la
nuit lorsque ayant franchi seul le
méridien gouessant il a pris place à
bord d'un bateau de la marine nationale
l'élan un reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux à brest jacques douai et
françois tonner la nuit dernière à bord
du remorqueur élan
gérard d'aboville se dégourdir un peu
les jambes sur le pont d'un navire après
ses 73 jours de mer sur son canot de 5
mètres 60
il vient de franchir le méridien
gouëssant son exploit est homologué
est-ce que tu aurais préféré arriver
jusqu'à bresse avec terreur plutôt que
de faire remorquer
oui mais enfin
je peux pas dire que ce soit très
important ce qui était important c'était
quand même d'avoir d'avoir un point bien
déterminé parce que sinon
on peut très bien aller se faire
rechercher à 8 jours en mer mais
à partir de là je savais dès le départ
que brest c'était extrêmement difficile
d'y aller à l'aviron parce que je suis
un bateau qui n'a pas beaucoup de
puissance et autour dit si ya pas mal de
caillou est courant il ya beaucoup de
navigation et
ça aurait été très difficile voire même
dangereux
pourrais tu nous raconter comment s'est
passée ta traverser oui c'est difficile
en deux mots parce que ça s'est passé de
façon bien diverses
je peux vous dire c'est que depuis le
départ je pense à l'arrivée au petit
jour c'est le goût du chemin brest est
en vue le navigateur solitaire va faire
son entrée à la rame ou une revient dans
son canot pour reprendre ses avirons
gérard alors ce sens et ce sont vos
derniers instants de navigation là pour
l'instant des temps morts
quoi
le ressentez-vous à la proche de brest
roche je ressens pas grand chose depuis
deux trois jours parce que
réalise pas tellement
alors vous sortez le pavillon là
le soleil se lève
après quelques heures de repos après sa
victoire c'est le dernier effort vers le
bassin du port de commerce
il va refaire des gestes rodez qu'il a
accompli pendant deux mois et demi dans
l'atlantique pour parcourir 5200 km de
newport angoissant
et
non
oui
est-ce que vous choquer aussi plaît vous
à l'entrée du goulet il va retrouver son
épouse 7 par an et guillaume son jeune
fils qui sans bien comprendre va faire
avec son héros de perles et quelques
milles qui ne sépare encore de la terre
ferme
quels souvenirs pour cet enfant de 5 ans
voiliers remorqueur canot à rames de
l'école navale l'escort et spectaculaire
chaque marin sur ces embarcations salut
et partage la gloire de gérard
d'aboville avec les terriens brestois du
dimanche
ça y est le nom voyage est terminé ahuri
gérard d'aboville est surpris de
l'accueil qu'on lui paye n'en revient
pas à peine le temps de poser le pied à
terre
il est happé par la foule des
journalistes et ses amis qui vont le
porter en triomphe après le ses rangs il
lui faut maintenant affronter la
célébrité c'est bien bouffer tout du
long
une victoire technique ou la tête pour
une fois a sans doute été plus fort que
les jambes
qu'est ce qui m'a poussé au départ ça a
été un intérêt plutôt technique et je me
suis toujours intéressé aux bateaux aux
petits bateaux et j'avais constaté que
les précédentes traverser à l'aviron
dans l'atlantique soit dé traversée en
solitaire plus courtes ou différentes
soit des traversées par équipage de deux
avaient été faites sur des bateaux qui
n'avaient pas été conçues spécialement
pour et j'ai pensé qu'il serait
intéressant de concevoir un bateau pour
ça et qu'on arriverait ainsi à aller
beaucoup plus vite et avec ce que
beaucoup plus de confort et de sécurité
et ça s'est passé un peu comme on le
pensait alors votre bateau est une
véritable merveille technique est ce que
vous pensez que ce brevet pourrait être
acceptée par exemple pour servir de
bateau de sauvetage sur les cargos et
les pétroliers ou les paquebots
non je ne le pense pas c'est pas là
qu'il faut chercher d'ailleurs une
finalité à cette affaire c'est un bateau
qui est parfait mais il est parfait pour
un bonhomme tout seul qui traverse
l'atlantique ou qui fait un long voyage
à l'aviron
donc comme bateau de sauvetage voyez que
pour un cargo il ya un équipage de 30 ça
ferait quand même beaucoup de petits
bateaux le long du bord
avec nos envoyés spéciaux nous avons
cité à brest la coordination des
reportages de fête à paris par pierre
jean petit gérard d'aboville sera l'un
des invités de marque question de temps
l'émission de la rédaction d'antenne 2
dans une première partie consacrée aux
héros de l'atlantique et où le rameur du
morbihan retrouvera alain bombard
l'aviateur maurice bellonte et les
américains qui ont traversé l'atlantique
en montgolfière une séquence présentée
par jean-pierre elkabbach
l'autre partie de ceux question de temps
traitera des sur régénérateur c'est un
domaine d'une importance exceptionnelle
de la france pour ne dépendre de
personne développe vous le savez son
programme de production d'énergie dans
diverses directions entre autres être
construit cinq centrales nucléaires par
an et elle est en avance dans ce domaine
mais une trentaine d'autres pays nous
ont suivis dans la même boire c'est bien
bouffer tout du long
une victoire technique ou la tête pour
une fois a sans doute été plus fort que
les jambes
qu'est ce qui m'a poussé au départ ça a
été un intérêt plutôt technique et je me
suis toujours intéressé aux bateaux aux
petits bateaux et j'avais constaté que
les précédentes traverser à l'aviron
dans l'atlantique soit dé traversée en
solitaire plus courtes ou différentes
soit des traversées par équipage de deux
avaient été faites sur des bateaux qui
n'avaient pas été conçues spécialement
pour et j'ai pensé qu'il serait
intéressant de concevoir un bateau pour
ça et qu'on arriverait ainsi à aller
beaucoup plus vite et avec beaucoup plus
de confort et de sécurité
et ça s'est passé un peu comme on le
pensait alors votre bateau est une
véritable merveille technique à ce que
vous pensez que ce brevet pourrait être
acceptée par exemple pour servir de
bateau de sauvetage sur les cargos et
les pétroliers ou les paquebots
non je ne le pense pas c'est pas là
qu'il faut chercher d'ailleurs une
finalité à cette affaire c'est un bateau
qui est parfait mais il est parfait pour
un bonhomme tout seul qui traverse
l'atlantique ou qui fait un long voyage
à l'aviron
donc comme bateau de sauvetage voyez que
pour un cargo il ya un équipage de 30 ça
ferait quand même beaucoup de petits
bateaux le long du bord
avec nos envoyés spéciaux que nous avons
cités à brest la coordination des
reportages devait à paris par et pierre
chant petit gérard d'aboville sera l'un
des invités de marque question tant les
missions de la rédaction d'antenne 2
dans une première partie consacrée aux
héros de l'atlantique et où le rameur du
morbihan retrouvera alain bombard
l'aviateur maurice bellonte et les
américains qui ont traversé l'atlantique
en montgolfière une séquence présentée
par jean-pierre elkabbach
l'autre partie de ceux question de temps
traitera des sur régénérateur c'est un
domaine d'une importance exceptionnelle
la france pour ne dépendre de personne
développe vous le savez son programme de
production d'énergie dans diverses
directions entre autres elle construit
cinq centrales nucléaires par an et elle
est en avance dans ce domaine mais une
trentaine d'autres pays nous ont suivis
dans la même boîte
alors que la crise de l'uranium qui est
l'élément essentiel du nucléaire sera
dans vingt ans selon des techniciens
plus grave encore que celle du pétrole
maintenant or justement le surgénérateur
permet de multiplier par 70 ce qui est
probable proprement considérable les
ressources d'une nation en uranium
en fait cette deuxième partie de
question de temps que présentera but
berio et le début d'une opération
couplée antennes d'europe numéro un
c'est une série d'émissions qui
passeront sur nos écrans jusqu'au 29
septembre pour se terminer par un débat
public avec quatre parlementaires
appartenant aux quatre grandes
formations politiques et qui sont allés
en divers endroits du monde pour être en
mesure de faire le point sur ces
questions du nucléaire demain soir donc
amateurs 35,1 question le temps deux
parties particulièrement riche je crois
en informations diverses
l'invité du club de la presse d'europe
numéro un et ce soir madame marie-france
garaud qui fut entre autres la
conseillère du président georges
pompidou puis celle de monsieur jacques
chirac notamment quand il était à
matignon
notons que c'est la première fois que
marie france garaud participe un
programme radio de ce genre
voici un extrait du club de la presse de
ce soir
je salue tout à fait respectueusement la
candidature de monsieur michel debré
d'ailleurs pour l'instant il est le seul
être candidat et il est tout à fait
exact que sa candidature si tu veux
débat à un niveau l'idée de principe
refont véritable qui me paraît être le
seul auquel on puisse placer le débat
qui va nous occuper pendant les mois qui
viennent et qui engagent l'avenir du
pays je crois que monsieur michel debré
aborde les problèmes d'une manière tout
à fait élevé tout à fait respectable en
ce qui concerne les idées qu'il
développe
j'ai fait comme vous et j'ai écouté ce
qu'il a dit et en particulier j'ai
écouté l'émission de cartes sur table je
crois d'ailleurs si vous même monsieur
je crois qu'il avait sa vie j'ai eu
l'impression mais je ne sais pas si
c'est une impression je ne sais pas si
j'ai bien ou mal compris ou je n'ai pas
si je ne sais pas si ce mal impression
subsistera ou pas j'ai eu l'impression
que pour monsieur michel debré comment
dire sans schématiser mes hanches et
mathis toujours un peu le débat
économique le relève mike le
redressement économique du pays
conditionné en quelque sorte le des le
redressement politique
je me suis demandé si monsieur michel
debré d'analysé par redresse le pays
revenons nous les moyens d'avoir une
politique indépendant et je vous ai vu
personnellement je pense que le
redressement politique est premier je
pense que le politique breeam
l'économique
je pense qu'on ne doit pas dire donnons
nous les moyens économiques d'un
redressement politique je pense qu'on
doit décider d'avoir une politique
indépendante le décider et s'en donner
les moyens
éventuellement je crois par exemple que
lorsque monsieur quito a décidé de dire
hutteau soviétique
il s'est pas demandé s'il avait les
moyens économiques il a décidé de le
faire et il l'a fait je crois vraiment
pour moi personnellement que la primauté
du débat politique sur le débat
économique et certains évidente
nous retournons à brest mais cette fois
ci pour vous y montrer un robot
spécialisés qui vient de sortir des
ateliers et chantiers de bretagne
philippe dumez s'est rendu au centre de
recherches océanographiques de brest
pour y suivre les essais du robot
effectués dans l'un des bassins les plus
grands du monde avec l'espoir
naturellement que cet engin permettra de
trouver du pétrin voici team le premier
robot sous-marin conçu par la société
elf aquitaine pour l'exploitation
pétrolière en mer à partir de bateaux ou
deux plateformes comme ici en mer
d'iroise l'homme peut intervenir sans
trop de difficulté jusqu'à 300 mètres
d'épaisseur d'eau au delà c'est
dangereux cher est presque impossible
lorsqu'un forage en mer est terminée que
l'on a trouvé du pétrole
on installe au fond un appareil de
production très lourd avec des vannes de
sécurité pour éviter les fuites
intempestives un appareil donc très
complexe
cet énorme pièce blanche doit être
entretenue vérifier pour que la
production de pétrole se fasse sans
problèmes
c'est ce que pourra faire team au fond
de l'eau en mer d'iroise ou deux forages
d'exploration viennent de commencer
notre société nationale connaît déjà
certaines difficultés et pourtant il n'y
a qu' environ 100 m dos tout l'intérêt
d'un robot comme ceux télémanipulateur
d'intervention et de maintenance
surnommé team et qu'avec sa grue ses
deux bras et ses quatre caméras de
télévision il pourra intervenir
rapidement et avec précision sans
prendre de risque actuellement en essai
à brest il sera au large du gabon au
début de l'année prochaine mais ce n'est
encore qu'un prototype
un des objectifs de ce développement
s'est en fait d'aller plus loin et plus
profond que la capacité actuelle en
profondeur des plongeurs et peut-être
d'une façon non seulement plus
économique et plus sûr et vous pensez
que ça arrivera dans combien de temps
cet appareil est quasi opérationnel dans
je vous ai dit à peu près un an
on pourrait considérer que à terme de
quelques années
cinq ans lorsque les pôles les projets
réels par grande profondeur seront à
étudier à mettre au point cet appareil
pourra être intégré à des programmes de
développement industriel qu'on attend
impatiemment maintenant team a été
calculée pour pouvoir intervenir jusqu'à
600 mètres de profondeur d'eau mais
d'autres modèles pourront certainement
aller au delà
or les géologues pensent que certaines
zones maritimes profonde c'est à dire
vers 1000 mètres pourrait être le lieu
de grosses découvertes pétrolières
ce robot est donc un peu le symbole de
l'avenir du pétrole mais peut-être aussi
d'autres travaux sous-marins parce que
steam n'est pas spécialisée il emmène
avec lui les outils dont il aura besoin
et qu'ils utilisent avec ses pinces sa
force est bien supérieure à celle d'un
homme et il peut être aussi précis que
lui bien sûr puisque c'est un homme qui
le dirige depuis un bureau confortable
la conquête de la mère et de son sous
sol commence ce ne sera pas simple ni
bon marché mais c'est en tout cas plein
d'espoir parce que ces grands à
longchamp la principale épreuve de la
journée prix du prince d'orange et
revenez a dû mettre la gagnante du
crédit de l'année dernière quant au
tiercé le gagnant n'a été le 11 fit est
entraînée par des lois et monté par du
brut devant le 17 fast action hélas ce
dernier violent pirette bresse avait
raison hier soir de vous dire que les
places dans les boîtes de départ j'aurai
un rôle important
en effet le gagnant avec le numéro un à
la cote
les lettres chevaux du tiercé galope
dans la descente du tout anglais
mais à notre grande surprise depuis le
début dernier violent est toujours en
tête du peloton
bien qu'ils portent 60 kilos et demi le
point le plus élevé de la creuse pour
aborder la ligne droite dernier volant
suivi de voies sacrées charme bridge dan
iriti tête qui lui est lié et sa stature
10e prefon à mi-ligne droite petit est
casaque rouge de clown va plonger à la
corde pour venir déborder dernier
violent simultanément à l'extérieur face
texen kazakh est rayé orange et vert
toque orange accélère encore la lure
pour amorcer la lutte avec type est
d'animer le numéro 9 irissou sillage kit
est bien calé à la corde gardera
l'avantagent dernier violon se bat
jusqu'au bout
oui devant s'incliner devant sa station
en conservant tout de même la troisième
place car ces housses 17,1 qui
rapportent dans l'ordre pour 5 francs
3595 francs 50 et dans un ordre
différent pour 5 francs 7 105 francs 707
francs
la météo pour demain dans l'est le matin
encore des pluies et orages surtout sur
les alpes le jura et les vosges
amélioration avec éclaircies d'après
midi et sur les autres régions le temps
sera relativement bon malgré quelques
brumes matinales avec des nuages
passagers l'après midi pouvant
s'accompagner d'ondés et de rage dans
l'ouest et le sud ouest du pays les
températures resteront élevées pour la
saison dernier journal à 23h25 c'est
patricia jean monnet qui vous présentera
demain midi à antennes de midi est
l'invité et monsieur boiteux président
directeur général de l'électricité de
france et demain soir vous retrouverez à
20 heures patrick poivre d'arvor et
n'oubliez pas un question de temps
particulièrement intéressante
après le journal de 20 heures dont soir
merci